my boys e torniamo dal nostro gap in
azione diavolo hai fatto a casa nostra e
identificativo
chissà come ma solo io ma cosa vuoi che
sia questo le fa vedere ma se provo
sì certo vede effettivamente è molto più
amati lasci un minuto allora ragazzi
diciamolo perché abbia una base così pro
ma allora quel che vuole un attimo ero
fuori intento cioè ragazzi guardate la
nostra base
a parte i digimon si è evoluta fa schifo
mon el huni da schifo nati però la pensa
che bisogna fare è far evolvere il piano
di sopra perché ancora legno e mica con
sotto lo sai
allora lo faremo con caratteriali erano
quelli che erano ma stiamo andando
avanti è bellissimo invece era crollata
la buona giornata lavate gli avevo
dovuto arrivare parlando gabini amoroso
ha detto già creato una base di due ore
buttate lì c'è invece no dai buoni da
ieri prima e da allora poi fai una cosa
fai una cosa io prendo un po di legna
dalle chat si è il mio obiettivo era
fare una stalla per i cavalli perché si
dilunga non ti ricordi l'altra volta
quindi mentre il tuo upgrade io prendo
un po di legna dalla cesta e vedo se
riesco a fare sta benedetta stalla sedi
basta però credo di sì è vero forse per
rimaniamo un po caroccia tutto riparato
il popolo da emettere rispetto alle
scale alle scale scorte nell'altro
episodio
mamma mia ma quella la base secondo me
era anche più sicura perché esatto la
potevi entrare da anche noi che infatti
l'incredibile bastano mai veramente al
limite ma comunque spetta prima di
suonare sui prima di suonare prima di
trattare la storia ci vuole la trombetta
propizia ma da dove stai sono andare
alla massiccia in burqa nature rometti
la bocca
esatto in un occhio a come è possibile
da due di scenario nel libro si bravo
bello provare la batteria che stanno li
sopra io sono me insieme
vai vai vai due muri facciamo facciamo
inconscia bene che canzone suoniamo io
con te aver dimenticato la cosa più
importante
ecco dipingiamo le pitture rupestri
della base bellissima ho scritto questo
è secondo me
e giusto siamo ora che l'ha iscritto
l'abbiamo fatto noi è un ramo rientra
legge ed esce perché diceva vergono
possiamo toccarlo il carpaneto ora ci
vuole la stalla pro per il cavallo si
ricorda le scale non è un problema
no aspetta il cavallo però che cosa stai
facendo piano ce la faccio aspetta già
fatta con un po numeri da tipo
condimenti la macchina con un po di
sofferenza animale
vabbè ci faccio delle mura attorno e
togli cavallo sono varie le mura e non
posso essere ok andiamo invitate a posto
ok perfetto e vorrei fare i tetti quelli
aventi vediamo se li faccia anche il
jukebox non so dove non lo so dove che
c'è il pacchetto la vera medicina centro
la pioggia entro la quale devono bere
anche i cavalli ci sta ci sta
è vero era bella sta tra l'altro che
possiamo fargli l'abbeveratoio glielo
faccio quello mobile tempo vendite come
quando e vorrei scrivere e cavallo
proprio verso il cavallo pro perfetto
dai non la vado a prendere più gol ho
mai capito un po di gravissimo poi non
so come fanno gli altri sulla regione
giuseppe io posso
mauri è che sono a giorgio ora paolo in
fa una cosa nella editing per dare più
lavoro tra editing
io sto fermo e lui mette la musica dj
giampy 3 2 1
[Musica]
la piazzola si segnale e poi cosa devo
fare lo aspetta stalla pro facciamo
problema stata facciamo una porta a
singola poi volevo farla porta da
pagliaccio
ma scusa non puoi mettere un frame è ma
basta uno dice ci passa al cavallo si
parlo dico era più bello c'era più da
ballo dove dio che fanno bene solo no
materiali sky
si no ci sei tu troppo ma no ma ci deve
essere assolutamente un modo ecco la
apple ha lo sfondo lo stato bravo
perfetto dimmi che poi ci metti un
secondo entrare oggi è bravissimo
ragazzi sembra che non l'ho proposta
alla prove non perfetto aver fatto la
stalla l'abbiamo non si sa chi è
dobbiamo fare è quanto abbiamo potuto
attaccare ogni giorno trovo un cinghiale
quando me lo aspettavo
però noi siamo in numero numeri ma come
scala la manovra venga skype ma mancato
nemmeno mi ha fatto male che ti voglio
vicino vetta con l'arco con l'arco lo
colpisce con l'arco madonne esaminando
spada la mamma mia mamma mia lo
colpiscono fatta no no no no perché è un
po un casino per l'arco aspetta non l'ho
trovato
alle spalle marrano bravo ma non si sa
quando si dice le spalle a vela è
l'animale
si fa per non tua vita mea come si fa
per non eliminati ed ecco il sasso o
penso con laccetto ma quel senso ma però
in delinque quello perfetto perfetto
continuiamo trony parecchie riserve non
fare più scrap perché il next level e
trasformare la nostra base in una base
praticamente di metallo che l'hai di
flash le loro pure quei razzi
ok quindi contiamo metallo niamo non non
ci dà facendo niente la radiazione
avevano nulla a meno male allora
possiamo dare anche una mamma mia magari
qua ma c'è un buco
hai visto mai uno spunto dalla bici
quando salutare vediamo dove qua dentro
no c'è la scala per andare qui sopra
adesso c'è qualcosa qui questi sono
posti enormi ma sicuramente questo post
è pieno di roma tivat e la porta qua ci
troviamo le armi fucili ma gara cioè la
batteria del mio iphone guarda sul
codice iniziata schiacciato qualcosa che
abb e nicole coste con domenico paura ho
fatto certo è partito un counter equa
aiuto aiuto ai lieviti aspetto perché
devi darmi una mano una base militare
quando sarà schiacciato e c'è scritto
come cosa bruttissima c'è scritto brutto
attacco iniziato 14 eccola ma se non sai
cosa hai fatto mi sono attivato gli
elicotteri da guerra
quindi cosa vuol dire a noi in teoria
bruteforce attacco vuol dire che tu stai
creando a ok non che bombardano quindi
vedi qua dentro c'è un attacco e tra 14
minuti
è nostro la roba speriamo che sia quello
che questa è una mia prometto cari ci
bombardano non lo sappiamo io e spero di
no non lo so devo morire o si può aprire
qua attivato per favore il tuo caschetto
buona sei ragazzi ma io non ho niente
cioè io non so dove mi prendo io prendo
il times
no ragazzi inquinamenti tutto room amico
tutto sta roba molle schermano io non ci
credo
una mail box cioè la mail box c'era voi
ovviamente la dobbiamo mettere questi ci
mandano posta ok cosa qua si può creare
primi bottone è tutto ok io cd condotto
accorciando così vogliono io bravo sul
piatto c'è gente va sopra le montagne ma
sopra l'ho visto test ho visto uno
quanto si sicuri questa affermazione
vogliono rubarci la nostra ci sono visto
proteggiamo la con la nostra vita vanno
mai al 113
speriamo ma dove l'hai visto
io non vorrei che siano andati verso la
nostra base dove ca volare la norma per
dirla per fortuna ho visto allora non mi
è stato mai visto ho visto eccolo eccolo
vedo meglio vedove dove ma in fondo non
ce la farà mai arrivare fin qua bisogna
prenderla dove scappare
se prendi il mio arco te lo do con le
frecce in più
io mi tengo la lancia di roccia e la
pistola dai dieci secondi tieni premuto
dall'altro per mirare 3 sinistro per
sballare 1 occhi che esplode quest mode
ma non si perdono la teoria la teoria no
subito evidente che non diventa mai non
dentro come non dentro no lei pagati da
come non ci credo vado ci creava prendi
altro ma poi li ho pagati entro a casa
magari facciamo tutto senza ci da fare
titolo la metà dei miei dai ok ma poi
non pagati entra castiga mamma mamma mia
incredibile ma non importa è tranquillo
sa nostro quarto un altro anche un po
c'è alcuno shot gun dove ti prendi per
gli shock via via carlo fucile perfetto
ragazzi vi assoluta corriamo per te la
sei cavata festa aspetta aspetta mi sto
prendendo tutto se per caso rimane
praticamente abbiamo il fucile a pone
quando lo sci a maso lamenta il capo del
serve per adesso siamo noi
no no veramente ora mi arrabbiavo
ceretta ma torniamo a chia ragazzi cosa
piano abbiamo fatto bene ma mi pare che
esistevano base dei processi la pazienza
di primo farci 2000 proiettili adesso
non so come la base ancora vive ma hanno
aperto hanno aperto il pagliaio
ci hanno rubato gli allegati hanno
rubato ma lele cavallo mi potevano male
ci hanno dato il cavallo no non è ancora
dentro ancora di entrare
secondo me non sono riusciti a rubarlo
perché era poi d'accordo perché ora di
vedere che cosa hanno rubato dentro
stalla pro ok non a differenza di
controlla controllo niente io entro
veloce chiudo dentro velo centro veloce
qualcuno ci sembra tutto a posto poi
vedere
mi sembra tutto ok adesso per due cose
importantissime intanto prendo del club
in testa ci facciamo i letti ci facciamo
il cane anti proiettile faccio due rally
dell'udc e quello vado a vedere un
attimo se c'è qualcosa arrivati pativa
di un secondo lì io mi sono fatto la
carne o questo dovrebbe un buon pranzo
un sacco di mele un po d'acqua
abbastanza cose non voglio morire mai
ho trovato un piccolo re quindi niente
però mi ricordo che qua dentro c'era un
sacco di roba guardona timi miniere al
volo non ho il caschetto non vedo nulla
mannaggia allora dolce mi serve uno
studente paradiso tanzi ma anche il
cappello da minatore alta vediamo vado a
vedere se c'è qualcosa che senti senti
senti e dai paparazzi ho detto ragazzi
questo è stato un episodio
incasinatissima abbiamo la nuova base ma
ci stanno attaccando che lo vedrete nel
prossimo episodio ragazzi un disastro
perché gli sia piaciuto come sergio il
video più il momento mi piace iscritti
alla gara e la giulietta mi sento al
prossimo vita della ragazza
[Musica]